témoignage à présent dans le 7-8 de ce
11 décembre xavier à 54 ans séropositifs
depuis 1987
comment vit-il sa maladie au quotidien
quel regard portent les autres sur lui
un témoignage recueilli par catherine
mulato le 1er décembre c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida nous
sommes ici à montigny au cyberespace
santé avec vous l avis ray coquet
bonjour bonjour je commence par dans
votre âge vous avez 54 ans et je vais
vous présenter vous avez un métier mais
vous avez aussi une spécificité médical
puisque vous êtes séropositif depuis
maintenant en 1985 de plus 25 ans alors
aujourd'hui on a tendance à dire que le
sida on ne meurt pas si vous êtes ici
avec mon plateau c'est pour témoigner
déjà déjà de la difficulté d'être malade
parce que si certains ne meurent pas du
sida il ya malgré tout des traitements
qui sont qui sont assez loin d'avoir
parlez nous de votre traitement vous
suivez tous les jours je sais tous les
jours le matin de 2 g le matin de l'élu
le soir c'est pas le plus difficile à
faire le plus difficile ce sont les
effets secondaires que l'on va avoir et
ses effets secondaires
ce n'est pas le ce qu'elle a confié
papier il faut ne jamais les oublier
parce que sinon à ce moment là on va
avoir un virus qui va devenir qui va
échapper et qui va reprendre le dessus
et la créer des problèmes et là on sera
vraiment malade parce que quand vous
dites on est on est on
on est malade non je suis porteur du vih
mais je ne suis pas malade
par contre j'ai des effets secondaires
justement quels sont ses effets visuels
r d effets secondaires et ça doit
dépendre des traitements ça va dépendre
de mon patrimoine génétique ça va
dépendre de mon histoire thérapeutique
c'est mon ancienneté dans la maladie et
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes avec
les directs pendant de nombreuses années
maintenant ça a été réglé
mais ils ont des problèmes de 2 sur la
répartition des graisses on peut avoir
un ventre assez important et puis migrer
et intégrer l'éducation
est-ce qu'on partait mais j'avais un
petit ventre plat jeu plus plaisant faut
dire aussi que c'est parce que ça parle
le même ça ça des effets qu'ils sont
quand même grave vous dire ce ventre il
est il va mettre de la graisse autour du
coeur et vous allez risquez d'avoir des
infarctus beaucoup plus jeune que la
normale en préparant comme si j'avais bu
énormément de bière pendant l'année non
pas du tout je déteste ça mais et c'est
bon mais c'est pas je peux pas toutes
façons je peux pas boire d'alcool avec
les médicaments s'accompagne pas
d'alcool une modification physique en
préparant les missions vous m'avez dit
ça joue aussi sur la fatigue est
certaine fatigue même subite immédiat
c'est une fatigue qui totalement
imprévisible c'est à dire que vous dites
ça y est c'est formidable je voulais
sortir en boîte ou jouer au théâtre avec
mes amis avec ma famille et claque vous
êtes plier vous pouvez vous allez faire
mais dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles et ça c'est absolument
imprévisible pourquoi parce que les
médicaments ils ont empêché en partie
l'absorption du sucre et de façon un peu
comprenais pas bien encore c'est des
choses qu'on ne connaît pas bien et là
ça provoque des fatigues des états de
fatigue qui parfois mon été jusqu'à moi
m'empêcher de travailler que moi qui
suis très active voire un hyperactif il
ya des fois où je ne pouvais pas
travailler ça m'arrive moins qu'avant
parce que les traitements se sont un peu
améliorées
en tout cas les miens mais pour la
majorité des personnes vivant avec le
vih
c'est pas le cas alors c'est un fait moi
qui entraîne aussi un mauvais sommeil le
sommeil peut être fortement pas toujours
spice et ça va dépendre des personnes
mais chez 30 40 à 60% des personnes ça
va provoquer une espèce de
deux choses extrêmement bizarre donc
assez le sommeil donc si vous avez un
travail comme moi vous vous levez le
matin avec un sommeil qui et comment
vous avez fait justement dans le cadre
de votre travail mais je suis arrêté me
suis arrêté alors j'ai repris mon
travail mais parce que j'ai changé de
médicaments mais ça a été j'ai eu des
périodes extrêmement difficile et on
présume que dans la vie professionnelle
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
illuminé
si vous avez un travail en plus avec des
variables ça devient un travail et de
serveurs c'est extrêmement difficile et
autres effet un des médicaments
je trouve cette importance votre
témoignage parce que on m'oublie
justement on ne pense pas notamment à
cette jeune génération qui sait
peut-être les effets des médicaments et
un effet que vous m'avez relaté je ne
connaissais pas c'est la disparition
parfois de la mémoire dite immédiate ce
qui est d'ailleurs vous allez faire
quelque chose vous allez ouvrir un
livret puis veut dire mais qu'on fait
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai ouvert ce livre
un petit peu comme comme si vous aviez
vieilli prématurément alors c'est pas
grave c'est réversible mais c'est un peu
déstabilisant
c'est un peu déstabilisant et du coup si
vous n'êtes pas prévenu de ce type
d'effets secondaires vous allez vous
demander mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive
alors ça c'est rien à la limite mais
ajoutés à la fatigue à ces problèmes de
modifications corporelles a laissé plus
ces problèmes le quine ou risque
d'atteinte broker assez pour les kivu
risque d'atteindre mes reins qui ne se
voit pas tout c'est pas mal tout
s'accumule effet que c'est une vie qui
est en termes justes biomédicale qui
compliquait difficile donc c'est le vih
c'est pas fini malheureusement non là on
a parlé de l'aspect biomédicale médical
on se rend compte que c'est lourd à
porter on va parler dans quelques
instants vous aussi vous parler des
conséquences sociales parce qu'elles
sont effectivement également importante
on va faire une première pause dans
cette émission on va aller à la
rencontre de l'association hf prévention
c'est une association qui évidemment
lutte contre le sida est fait de la
prévention et nous l'avons rencontrée
sur un lieu de rencontre c'était à
plaisir c'est volontairement de nuit
pour que la zone ne soit pas
reconnaissable que jérôme andré nous
entraîne au coeur de la forêt il faut
enjamber plusieurs ornières marché à
l'aveuglé l'endroit paraît derrière des
fougères
ce qui frappe ce sont ces sacs poubelles
accrochés aux arbres
donc là il ya beaucoup donc de sopalin
mais pas beaucoup de préparatifs ce qui
est embêtant pour nous parce que du coup
il s'essuie avec le saut paris et donc
du coup on voit qu'il n'aide pas
forcément de préservatifs ici nous
sommes dans une zone dite de
consommation sexuelles entre hommes
elle se situe sur le territoire de
plaisir chaque jour entre 100 et 150
personnes fréquentent les lieux se
défend ce soir là les 45 sont bien
remplies au sol pas de trace d'activité
sexuelle
un dispositif mis en place par
l'association hf prévention cela fait
huit ans qu'elle intervient sur ce
secteur c'est une zone très excentré par
rapport effectivement à la forêt c'est
donc un lieu où il ya donc de la
consommation sexuelle et nous
effectivement
mais des sacs poubelle pour que les gens
puissent mettre leurs déchets
préservatifs et c'est directement dedans
ce qui permet effectivement de garder le
lieu calme puisque du coup on ne voit
pas cette consommation sexuelle
si ce n'est avec les sacs poubelles
jérôme andré ne se contente pas
d'installer des sacs hf prévention
dispose d'un camping-car reconnaissable
ses animateurs vont au contact direct
des gens pour leur proposer des
préservatifs du gel notamment une écoute
surtout par souci de discrétion nous ne
filme n'ont pas ces personnes se sont
fait partie de la chaîne prévention fait
de la prévention santé et on vient
régulièrement donc sur les lieux et on
propose du matériel de prévention vous
est ce qu'il faut parfait et puis on
propose des dépistages rapides dépistage
rapide en fait on vous prend donc une
goutte de sang et puis on peut vous dire
non c'est effectivement est en situation
de séropositivité ou non et c'est
immédiat résultats immédiats en fait les
trois quarts des personnes qui viennent
ici sont des hétérosexuels père de
famille on a des cadres supérieurs des
csp + plus comme on peut le dire on
n'est pas là pour juger leur sexualité
ou leur dire qu'ils sont gays ou quoi
que ce soit on est là pour leur apporter
vraiment des outils de prévention de
manière à ce qu'ils prennent le moins de
risque pour eux mais aussi pour leurs
familles
chez eux puisque effectivement ans
contaminant eu quelque part ils peuvent
aussi contaminer leurs femmes dans le
camping-car offert par la fondation
pierre bergé les bénévoles de
l'association offre donc un dialogue et
quand la confiance est installé il est
possible de pratiquer un test vih
minutes
les personnes qui sont sur les lieux de
rencontres exr sont des personnes qui
n'auront jamais en centre de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit est encore en moins
en laboratoire pourquoi parce qu'ils ne
pourront pas dire à leurs femmes qui
sont allées en centres de dépistage ils
ne pourront pas donner leur carte vitale
pour se faire rembourser de laboratoire
c'est trop compliqué pour eux et on est
souvent donc le seul endroit où ils
peuvent faire un test immédiatement sans
culpabilité puisqu'on est dans le non
jugement
et effectivement ils peuvent le faire de
manière complètement anonyme et gratuite
il faut
récolter quelques gouttes de sang qu on
mélangera au flacon numéro un qui va
séparer les molécules le flacon numéro 2
qui permet de savoir si le test a bien
fonctionné et le fac on numéro 3 qui dit
le résultat qui précise bien si oui ou
non le test est positif ou négatif
et on sait tout de suite le sait
immédiat le résultat est immédiat
à chaque prévention est une association
yvelinoise devenu national elle dispose
d'antennes à lyon en vendée dans le pas
de calais et prochainement dans
l'essonne et dans le val de marne sur
les deux départements dont il a la
charge
les yvelines et le val d'oise l'an passé
jérôme andré a distribué 35 mille
préservatif de retour ici à montigny au
cyberespace sont avec aviez ray coquet
on a parlé des conséquences médicales de
la maladie du veillât jousse est
séropositif le rappel depuis 1987
on va parler d'un autre aspect c'est la
réalité sociale alors quand on apprend
qu'on est séropositif il ya 25 ans en
plus comment on réagit d'abord dans la
famille et comment réagissent les amis
il ya 25 ans le
d'apprendre autre est séropositive
c'était une annonce d'être mort dans les
dix ans au maximum au maximum
aujourd'hui c'est plus vraiment une
annonce de mort biologique et c++ une
annonce de mort ou en tout cas de
difficultés sociales majeures
imaginez je fais comment si je lui dis à
mes voisins boxing day à la prenne et
que ses voisins ont des enfants qui les
amène à l'école et que ma fille
valettois les ondes hier mais si le père
est séropositif est ce que sa fille les
parents par exemple vous imaginez type
discrimination justement cette
discrimination
on voit pas dans le vert d'un
séropositif on serre pas la main d'un
séropositif on embrasse pas un
séropositif
alors qu'il faut quand même rappeler
c'est une maladie qui s'attrape par le
sens pas transmis alors j'ai vécu dix
ans avec mon ex épouse et on a partagé
beaucoup de choses on a pris des
précautions avec la capote mais hormis
sa ont partagé le verre
parfois la bourse donc on a fait du
camping ensemble et voilà donc il s'est
jamais rien passé et il se passe jamais
rien si vous l'avez vécu vous cette
définition alors la discrimation elle
est toujours insidieuse et n'est pas moi
je suis assez dynamique donc je ne me
mets pas en position de
de discriminer rarement mais ça m'est
arrivé par exemple chez le dentiste 40%
des dentistes refusent de soigner une
personne qui dit qu'elle est
séropositive
pour des raisons qui ne sont absolument
pas scientifique se transmettent pas
comme ça d'autant que les médecins et
dentistes et comme le reste de la
population doit savoir que quand on est
soigné
la plupart des personnes à 99 % des
personnes soignées avec les trithérapies
faisons une charge virale qui est
tellement faibles qu'elles ne peuvent
pas contaminer donc l on peut qu elles
peuvent pas et ça c'est pas su vraiment
et dentistes ils sont tellement effrayé
que il va ils ont tellement peur que ces
et puis non pas la formation ont
malheureusement et pourtant c'est
extrêmement simple
par contre ils risquent d'attraper les p
tits et l'hépatite b
un certain nombre d'autres d'autres
maladies avec les projections salivaires
et de sang qui sont aussi extrêmement
embêtante
et au niveau des amis les amis niveau de
la famille au niveau des amis est ce que
c'est ce que les gens se sont détournés
ou est-ce contraire on est venu autour
de vous et en général on suscite pas un
mouvement large d'approbation surtout il
ya 25 ans a donc c'est plutôt de la
compassion plutôt bien mais la
compréhension aussi et 25 de
l'incompréhension il ya des cousins qui
les cousines qui n'ont pas compris
voilà mes et puis d'autres amis et des
amis que je n'ai plus revu je me suis
douté un peu pourquoi mais donc on ne se
fait pas d amis enfants séropositifs
s'est pas fait une super idée
pour ce faire des amis on se refait un
nouveau cercle dernier après cette
difficile c'est plus difficile de faire
une action de ce qu'il est difficile
forcément c'est plus restants et pour la
vie intime
j'ai envie de dire comment ça se passe
vous étiez marier alors j'étais mariée
j'ai divorcé et puis ben j'ai recherché
une nouvelle compagne et c'est difficile
parce que vous sentez
vous sentez en devoir de direction
positive si vous êtes un peu intime mais
mieux quand même
c'est comme ça le fait pas et donc avec
l'épée en se disant mais attention pour
enfin on va on va être rachetée et donc
la plupart d'eux des personnes
séropositives sont très très isolée
elles ont pas de compagnon peu de tissu
social parce qu'elle se renfermer raison
c'est tellement douloureux de se faire
racheter par quelqu'un on a envie
d'aimer billet je ne sais pas facile en
temps normal mais alors en plus vous
lancer là bas cool je suis séropositif
généralement c'est le jeu lancé avec le
sourire parce que vous dites que c'est
avec le sourire mais on voit la réalité
qui avait rêvé aussi un canton vous
entendre sa coupe ça vous coupe
quels conseils vous auriez envie de
donner aux je pense aux jeunes notamment
parce que je pense que le vih est
quelque chose qui peut être se banalise
beaucoup dans la pensée des jeunes en
disant effectivement maintenant à des
traitements on n'en meurt pas ça va même
sur la tronche hop on pourra toujours
prendre un médoc et ça ira
qu'est ce qu'on a envie de leur dire ces
jeunes banic que ce qui m'importe en
arriver c'est de prendre soin de soi et
que c'est très c'est pas si facile que
ça mais que c'est une belle démarche
cette démarche elle permet de prendre
vraiment plaisir pas le plaisir
seulement dans l'instant mais le plaisir
sur la durée donc des tares d'un stand
on prend plaisir et pour ça il faut
aussi prendre soin de soi parce que si
on prend pas soin de soi ici on se
protège pas être pour l'instant avec la
capote qui est bien d'ailleurs plein de
gens savent pas bien l'utiliser ailleurs
des choses à faire là dessus il faut
mettre beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
gel ça c'est être le secret d'état et là
on peut effectivement prendre plaisir et
ça dure voilà c'est la durabilité du
plaisir qui est importante mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter la
durabilité
merci xavier ray coquet d'avoir répondu
à vos questions de dt les fictions
disent merci beaucoup
témoignages recueillis par catherine
château avec l'aide des chefs prévention
la suite du 7-8 avec la page
environnement du mardi et valéry
auribeau programme le réchauffement
climatique ça ne se ressent pas
aujourd'hui dans les rues yvelinoise et
pourtant c'est toujours d'actualité
et pour l'instant justement la neige
elle pourrait faire son retour dans les
prochaines heures en tout cas d'ici à
jeudi mais en très faible quantité le
département est en tout cas prêt on en a
parlé sur ce plateau
hier le plan neige est activé vendredi
matin premiers flocons de neige dans le
département et première mise en action
pour le dispositif de viabilité
hivernale actif depuis la mi novembre et
jusqu'au 15 mars pour l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise tout se pilote depuis
cet entrepôt à trappes
c'est là qu'est stocker le sel pour
l'hiver 1200 tonnes on a dix camions aux
neuf camions donc pour la casse qui est
un camion pour la ville de montier
bretonneau à montigny le bretonneux
justement c'est patrick râteau le
responsable de la voirie qui a l'oeil
sur le planning de ces cinquante agents
mobilisables 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
chacun a donc une tâche bien spécifique
et un secteur à traiter dans la ville et
dans un quartier bien défini les leçons
de l'hiver 2010 avec son lot de
véhicules bloqués sur les chaussées ont
été bien tirés des butins alerte météo
sont édités dès que besoin et chaque
équipe dispose d'une cartographie des
zones à déneiger
on sait également équipée de nouveaux
engins comme les mises en jambes salage
de boiry qui sont qui fond en hiver du
salage et dans d'autres saisons d'autres
prestations sur la ville
l'hydro gommage traitement des graffitis
plus de véhicules et des engins plus
performants sylvain charrier et
chauffeurs ce à l'heure tout est
automatisé depuis ce petit boîtier jaune
à l'intérieur du camion vous pouvez dosé
comment là
le pourcentage de 5 par rapport au
nectar et vous pouvez voir la largeur du
budget vous pouvez aussi régler demain
pour la saumure un système expérimental
sur montigny le bretonneux
c'est un mélange de sel d'eau qui fait
que quand on l'est quand on le met par
terre
la nef est normalement d'importance et
que la neige ne tient pas ne tient pas
par terre une bouillie de sel comme
l'appellent les spécialistes 80 % de
celles solide et 20% de selles liquides
un procédé qui sera actif à partir de la
mi-décembre
pas de neige annoncées dans les
prochains jours